new this morning the u.s is joining with
allies around the world to call out the
chinese government for a series of
cyber intrusions u.s intelligence
officials say they now have high
confidence that chinese hackers
were responsible for an attack on
microsoft's email server
software in march that affected tens of
thousands of customers around the world
chief white house correspondent nancy
cordes joins us now nancy good morning
so we hear a lot about russian cyber
attacks what's going on here
well cyber officials here in the u.s now
say that these chinese
efforts in a way are actually more
concerning vlad
because these hackers are actually on
the chinese government's
payroll a senior administration official
told
reporters that china's ministry of state
security quote
uses criminal contract hackers to
conduct
unsanctioned cyber operations globally
including
for their own personal profit this
official revealed that such hackers were
responsible for a ransomware attack
recently on an unnamed
american company holding their network
hostage in an attempt to extort
millions of dollars and the victims of
these intrusions aren't all
big companies they are schools cities
hospitals
pharmacies all over the world which is
why
today you're going to see this
unprecedented move
statements coming out from the u.s and a
host of global allies
australia canada japan the uk the eu
nato all condemning china for these
quote
malicious cyber activities and we are
just learning this morning that four
chinese nationals have
actually been indicted by a grand jury
in california for
allegedly hacking into dozens of
companies and government entities we
have reached out to the chinese embassy
for comment
but we have not heard back yet anthony
nancy cordes at the white house this
morning thank you nancy